I think at a point it's it's
probably a um not I wouldn't say easy
but it's it's reasonable that if you're
continuously getting a lot of love you
can like as a as a person you can
convince yourself you know I can trust
this yeah and I don't have to listen to
this other stuff and I mean if people
keep showing up to see you how you know
how right can the people be who are
always trying to take a chunk out of you
they almost need you there right you
know um yeah I just think it's I mean
your the length of your career is like
it's [__] awesome man it's just super
impressive L of my penis too yeah let's
not forget don't go back to that again
but I'm sorry I had
to I have it on Loop so it's hard for me
to get it out of my mind you know we all
do yeah no no we all
do yeah dude
I it seems like you still love it though
my penis yeah yes yeah I love I love
absolutely I love this job more than
anything in the world and and I find it
to be cuz everyone says to me like dude
when are you going to retire and when
you when's when you like you still have
fun and and I'm I don't know how yeah I
have more fun now than I and I don't
know the exact one that I maybe just one
day you realize you you
um you just kind of got into a rhythm
and you kind of know what you're doing
so you feel a little better cuz I did
tell George Carlin that one time I asked
him as an idiot I I didn't know what is
I just said what's it like to be you
where you got it all like you got it
yeah and he said what what are you
talking about I said you know you're
like you're George you don't go up there
and like eat [__] you're like you you
kill it every night cuz you're you're
you're polished prob what's it must be
nice to have that feeling when you go up
there that you're just going to nail it
again and he said I Ain like [__] I
don't know I'm still learning every day
I don't I even know what you're talking
about so part of me I think he meant you
know he's just a perfectionist but I
think it probably is nice to have a I
mean I do go up there now with a with a
pretty good I know of my my flow and my
outline of where I'm going to go and
what's going to you kind of I mean you
don't eat you don't bomb anymore because
you can't it's kind of bomb proof so you
know how to do the show you know how to
from you know how to take every crowd
and beginning to end you might have one
that just you know last week we had one
that the crowd wasn't so hot but we made
fun of the fact that the crowd wasn't so
hot then when then the crowd was great
like you just had to work them around
you you got to take a a two to a 10 yeah
just don't take a 10 to a two yes yeah
that's what you don't want to do yeah
God they were so good and then I [__]
it up thing yeah oh man I I was going to
do it again like very familiar taking a
two to a 10 but don't yeah you can do it
all right all right that's uh yeah so
how many days a week do you perform now
six six yeah my manager has a car
payment so I have to work yeah we got to
make sure yeah Ferraris man they don't
they don't pay themselves nice I'm not a
Ferrari guy no no I'm a pickup drug guy
yeah I mean I'm I'm a trucker hat and
this is this is me dressed up by the way
yeah yeah you make your clothes though I
like to look homeless so people don't
ask me for
money like that guy's broke it's a good
strategy yeah they never ask me that guy
doesn't have a [__] time don't ask
him yeah no strangers and no family they
won't come after you yeah you dress
broke no one will ask you for anything
yeah but you make your clothes is that
right I do I mean almost everything I I
kind of if I don't make full I will add
two or or do something like I'll add the
the the patch on the front or I'll add
this or add something some paint and do
something to it kind of make it mine
yeah I think it's cool man so you're
doing six nights a week um and I'm sure
this you know and I'm I'm partially
digging into this because again I want
everyone listening to this to kind of
get the full scope of you um and you've
been doing that how many years now
roughly um at the Luxor and and Vegas
and stuff about 30 something years okay
okay so 30 something and is Jeff Dunham
still performing out there or no I think
he comes in and out in and out and does
it but he's not there fulltime I don't
believe um there's so many shows that
you know that's another thing that's
changed with Vegas you know when when I
first started that's what I want to ask
you is how has like I guess cuz I would
imagine in the crowds you would see a
change or like yeah you know what I
guess what was it like when you first
started and what do they feel like now
it's it's it's completely different I'll
tell you I mean they still awes there're
still awesome audiences but yeah the
times have changed and the things and
the number of shows and like it sounds
weird though like when I started there
it was before MGM GR was built so there
was like there's no New York New York
there was no Bellagio there was no wind
there's no Encore so there was you know
Caesar's b a few other ones and that was
it so there on any given night there was
probably a dozen shows a dozen
showrooms and now there's 100 showrooms
yeah maybe yeah so all everything in
that aspect has changed to just the
growth and the and the number of of uh
shows that are there and the kind of
shows that are there you know when I was
there too when I first started they were
like Vegas like then that's where you go
to like you know retire you know and I
said no that's Branson [__] it's not
it's not Vegas so Branson yeah Branson's
were you not yeah not off forever not
Vegas know so I said Vegas is not that
what are you talking about they said
yeah Vegas is like you know Wayne Newton
and but I kept thinking I know but I
still thought it was a cool aspect to it
and then all of a sudden I mean within
the last 10 years it was like Elton John
well Selen was probably the first one
that made a big selenon came and uh that
was huge and and we had a joke when
she's working she's seleny on and she's
not she seleny off yeah but um she had
she had a this big thing and then they
got Elton John and they got Rod Stewart
and they got the Rolling Stones and then
the Eagles and and kiss and then all
sudden everyone wants to play Vegas yeah
and so you know you go there I'll be
back there today you go be flying then
you got everyone from Usher to you know
k Katy Perry to I mean everybody yeah so
it went from you know no one wanting to
play Vegas to being kind of a to a no I
need I need to play Vegas wow did you
did you have feelings about that like
cuz you were one of the first I stay I
stayed througho thick and thin yeah yeah
well I always had a feeling like from
the beginning I thought it was a great
gig I mean you're in Vegas and you're
not just the aspect not of idea of not
traveling um was also nice as well you
know You' stay in your instead of
getting on a bus in a hotel you you stay
in your own room yeah do a show and you
go home yeah that's very rare in the
show business to do that so oh you know
how many bus tours do you think you've
done in your career oh my God uh we th
thousands I mean that's all I did I
turned down the Vegas gig um in the
beginning CU I I was a bus guy yeah and
they kept asking me if I'd do the
residency and I said no and the guy
finally came back and said you know let
rethink think this you sure I said no I
don't want
to and then my guy says I think we
should do it and I'm like well I'll give
it like a year I'll give a year and then
I'll try it and I hated it yeah I
despised it I'm like I'm definitely not
signing up again so it was year over and
then all a sudden I found a little click
and it was like kind of getting
good and then I said yeah let's sign
again and now it's like of course I we
just signed again for six years so now
it's now it's a now it's a please let me
sign again kind thing you know I don't I
don't want to go back on the road yeah
well yeah um I definitely cannot hold a
candle to the amount of bus towards you
have done I but they they were fun and
but you know it's also you're putting
your life in danger too every night when
you do that you know you don't think
about it you know you're on a tour bus
in the middle of a a mountain in snow
and you're letting some guy you barely
know drive you around you know we had we
did we had bus drivers one night that I
I'm you know rest of the guys are all
asleep cuz I'm the only one that you
know I just did a show so we just FR Lou
in the front lounge with the with the
driver crazy every night and we Jam
sober yeah well me I have my little
crown on the Rocks yeah yeah um but not
not yeah I never really got too crazy I
was I was you know I was kind of I mean
I drank but that's about the the yeah
unless someone put something in my drink
um I just uh have my drink and I sit
there we listen to like country music
and just whatever and drive down the
road yeah and uh talking to the driver
and he says you know cuz he drove
everybody right so he said you know and
I used to drive Johnny Cash and I said
oh my God how do you go from like Johnny
Cash to [__] rock bottom and drive
driving carrat toop I mean drove [__]
Johnny Cash I'm sorry about this I'm
sorry about your career ending and he
said no this is great dude you're the
best you're like so much fun he said
when I was driving Johnny we do rails
off the [__] steering wheel and I'm
I'm literally like listening to him as
he's saying this we're driving I'm like
how many years ago was that he's like oh
God years I said but but you don't
anymore like you don't he's like no no
no I'm like you don't do lines anymore
off the [__] bus yeah imagine that
yeah so I I could so I'm like let's just
pull over and think this over for a
minute you know Jesus make sure that
you're not maybe we should drug test
this guy
yeah